One of the things that's often said about
technological advancements is that when technology
is advancing really rapidly, you can't see
it until later. When you're in the middle
of it. It can be hard to see even rapid technological
change because you are in the midst of it
every single day.
We are in the middle of an authoritarian explosion
right now, and if you've been in the middle
of the Trump presidency day to day as I have,
and as many of you have for the last, I don't
know, 11 1200 days roughly of Donald Trump's
presidency, you likely don't realize how quickly
things have gotten authoritarian and dictatorial.
We might have some general sense of it, but
what has happened in just the last two weeks,
really 12 days is shocking. And if someone
had told you the day Donald Trump was inaugurated,
you know, uh, in a 12 day period in 2020,
here's the list of authoritarian things this
man is going to do. Many of us, myself included,
likely would've said, there's no way it won't
happen. But we've slowly been desensitized.
It's slowly been normalized and it has happened
in the time since Donald Trump's acquittal
as Reddit user rustic gorilla astutely pointed
out, Donald Trump has vowed revenge on his
enemies list after being acquitted in a completely
sham impeachment since the acquittal, the
president said that these are people who will
suffer consequences for their role in impeachment.
That includes Adam Schiff and Jerry Nadler
and other Democrats. It even includes Republican
Mitt Romney for his one guilty vote on article
one of impeachment. Remember, impeachment
is the constitutionally outlined duty of the
house. A reporter asked Trump how he's going
to get revenge on those responsible. He responded,
you will see, this is dictatorial. Trump then
fired impeachment witnesses who showed up
and simply told the truth under oath as they
remember it from fired Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander Veneman, Trump fired ambassador
to the European union, Gordon Sunland. They
did nothing wrong. Trump simply doesn't like
what they said. When you tell the truth to
investigators under oath and Trump doesn't
like it, you lose your job. This is an authoritarian
nightmare. Trump's former chief of staff,
John Kelly rightly defended Colonel V Lieutenant
Colonel Veneman and Donald Trump attacked
Kelly tweeting. When I terminated John Kelly,
which I couldn't do fast enough, he knew full
well that he was way over his head.
Being chief of staff just wasn't for him.
He came in with a bang, went out with a whimper,
but like so many exes, he misses the action
and just can't keep his mouth shut, which
he actually has a military and legal obligation
to do. His incredible wife Karen, who I have
a lot of respect for, once pulled me aside
and said strongly that John respects you greatly
when we are no longer here. He will only speak
well of you wrong. Trump then, as we've already
discussed, got involved in the sentencing
of his associate Roger Stone interfering in
the trial tweeting quote, this is a horrible
and very unfair situation. The real crimes
were on the other side is nothing happens
to them, cannot allow this miscarriage of
justice. Again, I know I said this on rehashing
it. Trump is using the fact that people not
charged with crimes, that he happens not to
like haven't gotten prison time and therefore
stone shouldn't get seven to nine years.
Dictators do this. Dictators attack a justice
system that's working independently and not
considering the subjects relationship to the
president. Then when four prosecutors quit
because of Trump's own interference, Trump
attacks then to Geraldo Rivera saying over
the weekend quote, I don't think they quit
for moral reasons. I think they got caught
in the act by me. What am I going to do? Let
a man go to jail for nine years when murderers
aren't going to jail. You have some of the
most serious, horrible rapists and everything
else. They don't go to jail for nine years.
Once again, Trump not using any factual basis
to argue that seven to nine years is actually
out of line with federal sentencing guidelines,
but it's not just the prosecutors that Trump's
at Trump attacks. Then Trump attacks the judge
in the case, Amy Berman, Jackson saying quote,
is this the judge that put Paul Manafort in
solitary confinement, something that not even
mobster Al Capone had to endure?
How did she treat crooked Hillary Clinton?
Just asking, of course, remember Hillary Clinton
not charged with any crimes. And of course,
as I've already told you, based on the point
system that federal sentencing guidelines
employ seven to nine years was the correct
range for Roger Stone. And then lastly, he's
attacked the prosecutors. He's attacked the
judge. Trump then attacks one of the jurors
in the Roger Stone trial saying quote, now
it looks like the foreperson in the jury in
the Roger Stone case had significant bias.
Add that to everything else and this is not
looking good for the quote justice department.
Then he said, I didn't intervene here, but
I could have if I wanted to quote, the president
has never asked me to do anything in a criminal
case ag bar. This doesn't mean that I do that.
I do not have as president the legal right
to do so I do, but I have so far chosen not
to.
So to sum up the authoritarian nightmare of
the Roger Stone situation, you have Trump
attacking the sentence, attacking the prosecutors,
attacking the judge, attacking a juror and
saying he can intervene in any case if he
so pleases, and then getting the justice department
to change their sentencing recommendation.
There's not really any justice department
independence there. Trump then on Twitter
accuses the former director of the FBI, Robert
Mueller of lying to Congress. That's a crime
if true Trump says congratulations to attorney
general bill BARR for taking charge of a case
that was totally out of control and perhaps
should not even, should not have even been
brought. Evidence now clearly shows that the
molar scam was improperly brought and tainted.
Even Bob Mueller lied to Congress. That's
an allegation that the former FBI director
has committed a crime casually by the president
on Twitter. This is what goes on in countries
that most of us do not consider ourselves
to be equivalent to in terms of the functioning
of our systems, but we are seeing it right
here.
This would be enough for two terms, nevermind
12 days and in the same 12 day period. I don't,
I won't go into it in detail. Trump attacked
FBI director, Christopher Ray, former FBI
deputy director Andrew McCabe, withdrew the
nomination of Jesse Lou who oversaw the Roger
Stone case and McCain and McCabe's case has
head of the DC us attorney's office and on
and on and on. So when you put together just
the last 12 days, it's an authoritarian nightmare.
The likes of which we have not seen from a
president in the United States for a long
time. I would argue likely ever, unless someone
can give me an example of where we've seen
this level of authoritarianism, not in a four
year period, in a 12 day period by a president.
This is nothing compared to what we will see
in a potential Trump's second term. This was
12 days. Forget about, is it the 12 days of
Christmas, that song or 12 nights of Christmas?
I'm Jewish, I I, there's 12 nights somewhere.
I don't know. This is the 12 days of authoritarianism
under Donald Trump, and you could pick any
12 days and do something similar except he's
been madly and wildly emboldened by the impeachment
acquittal, which was predictable. We said
this would happen. It will get significantly
worse if Trump has given a second term. Let
me know what you think about these last 12
days of authoritarianism. I am on Twitter
at Deepak
and follow me
and send me your thoughts there.